HE'S ALSO BEEN INDICTED.
WE'LL KEEP YOU POSTED WITH MORE.
MEANTIME, AUTHOR AND COLUMNIST
MARK STEYN JOINS TO CHEW THIS
OVER.
DOES THIS SURPRISE YOU, MARK?
>> NO, NOT AT ALL, TUCKER.
IF YOU'RE ROAD TESTING NOW
LABELS FOR THE CREEPY PORN
LAWYER, WE SHOULD GO WITH CREEPY
PORN EXTORTIONIST.
I CONGRATULATE YOU, TUCKER,
BECAUSE YOU GRASPED THE ESSENCE
OF THIS CHARACTER.
AS WE TALKED, MENTIONED SIX
MONTHS AGO AFTER THAT INTERVIEW
AND THE REALITY OF THE SITUATION
HERE.
STORMY DANIELS IS STRIPPING ON A
18-INCH BAR IN RICHMOND,
VIRGINIA.
HOPING TO GET THE $5 AND HIS
SITTING THERE IN A $5,000 SUIT
AND MAKING TRIPS TO IOWA AND
NEW HAMPSHIRE.
IT TIES IN WITH EVERYTHING ELSE
YOU'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
LAST HOUR.
NO MATTER HOW OFTEN -- THEY'RE
BASICALLY LIKE KIND OF AN ARMY
OF YOSEMITE SAMS.
THEY KEEP STICKING THE DYNAMITE
DOWN THEIR OWN PANTS AND NO
MATTER HOW OFTEN BRIAN SELTZER'S
PANTS ARE DYNAMITED AND ANDERSON
COOPER'S PANTS ARE DYNAMITED AND
DON LEMONS PANTS ARE DYNAMITED,
THEY'LL FALL FOR THE NEXT CREEPY
PORN EXTORTIONIST THAT COMES
ALONG.
>> Tucker: I NOTICE A THEME HERE
WITH AVENATTI, AND HARVEY
WEINSTEIN AND MANY PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES.
WHAT ABOUT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND THEIR HAND MAIDENS ATTRACT
THEM TO THE WORST PEOPLE IN THE
WORLD?
IT'S ALWAYS THE UNUSUALLY BAD
PEOPLE THAT THEY WIND UP
CELEBRATING.
WHY IS THAT?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S TO DO
SOMETHING THAT ALAN DERSHOWITZ
WAS TALKING ABOUT EARLIER TODAY.
ONCE YOU DECIDED ON THE OUTCOME,
YOU'RE ACTIVELY INVESTED IN THE
OUTCOME.
IT AN OLD FLEET STREET CHAT.
I LOVE SEX SCANDALS.
FOR THE SEX.
THE MINUTE STORMY DANIELS WAS
PRESENTED AS A CAMPAIGN FINANCE
REFORM, THAT IS THE LEAST
INTERESTING SEX I'VE EVER HEARD
ABOUT.
THAT IS A FETISH THAT ONLY
DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA CAN GET
INTO.
THE IDEA THAT NOTHING ELSE IS
GOING -- SEEMS TO BE CLEAR
ENOUGH IN THE RUSSIA COLLUSION
THING, WE DON'T WE MERGE IT WITH
STORMY DANIELS BY MAKING THIS A
CAMPAIGN FINANCE REFORM
INFRACTION?
THAT'S A LOSING PROPOSITION FOR
ANYONE OTHER THAN CNN.
>> Tucker: SUCH A GOOD POINT.
I CAN SAY THIS SINCERELY, HE
REALLY WAS CREEPY.
IN ALL THE YEARS I WORKED WITH
OUR STAGE MANAGER, THE ONLY TIME
I'VE SEEN HIM USE PURELL.
HE'S THAT DIRTY.
>> NO, NO.
WEAR A HAZMAT SUIT NEXT TIME,
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: BY THE WAY, I WOULD
ALMOST NEVER -- I FEEL BAD ABOUT
SAYING -- DESCRIBING SOMETHING
THAT TOOK PLACE OFF CAMERA, BUT
THAT REALLY DID HAPPEN.
IT STUCK WITH ME EVER SINCE.
I NEVER MET A GUEST IN 22 YEARS
OF DOING THIS WHO WAS MORE
PERSONALLY MENACING AND DARK
THAN THAT GUY.
>> YOU CAME UP WITH THAT LABEL.
AND THE QUESTION IS WHY DID YOU
GET THE ESSENCE OF THE MAN AND
CNN AND MSNBC AND THE REST TRIED